people just coming up to me singing i'm
so excited
listen i get to wear six inch heels and
fringe
to work every morning so fun maybe you
can tell mario like
i used to think i was slater and i'm
like dad don't
ever do that in public dustin we're
discussing
but i just don't know yet in terms of
easter eggs for the original show like
that was one of the most fun things
about this i'm just hoping over here for
a principal title and a principal
building
reunion of the sorts stay tuned
[Music]
ah bayside
[Music]
alicia you guys are really young so i
want you guys to be honest with me
when this project fell in your lap had
you
heard of saved by the bell were you guys
a fan of the original
complete truthfulness i was completely
aware of the show
i had watched episodes growing up
because i'd watch reruns really early in
the morning on the weekends
and i distinctively remembered speaking
on the phone with my manager and making
sure i was like wait is
this that saved by the bell like is it
something different like
another very like i was like is it she
was like yes it is and i was like
wow we lived in a one like tv household
so whatever my dad watched we watched
which was like history channel and saved
by the bell and we were like yeah
saved um literally saved by the bell i
had not washed it
i knew the weight of it but i did not
watch it religiously like a lot
of people do i was a baby born in 2001 i
was watching
josh i hate to say it i hate to ask
myself like that
i'm a fetus and i did not watch the show
but i'm proud that i was aware of it
so at least give me credit for that i
was already a full-fledged
cranky adult by the time saved by the
bells showed up
they gave me this job and i went back
and looked at some of them i
thought the show was totally charming i
was like what do you need to remake this
for it's lovely
in your preparation for each of your
roles did you guys go back and watch
old episodes how did you react to the
fashion the acting the characters
all of that the fashion i would say
spot on like it's something i would wear
to
this day but it brought back a lot of
nostalgia because it reminded me of my
childhood we would sit around the tv and
watch this show and my dad really
thought he was mario lopez
and i think he was yeah he was more
excited i think than i was
because he was like oh if you book it
maybe you can tell mario like
i used to think i was slater and i'm
like dad don't
ever do that in public i had the
opportunity to actually bring my mom on
set and
that's when i was like oh don't cry
like even just thinking about it like
because she my mom is just a gem i love
her so much
alicia how about for you i definitely
did and it just
made things really surreal you know
the fact that i was going to be walking
through those bayside lockers or like
really sitting in the max where the
moments for me and
me and askity would have these looks and
like talks to each other all the time
girl like this is happening so watching
back it felt
really wacky and and crazy being like oh
my god i've sat in that max and
this is something that i watched and now
i'm sitting it's like mario
tv but now it's here although that show
was so fun and so wonderful
and served so many people this like warm
comfort
it also was full of a lot of ignorances
and a lot of
things that showed how not evolved the
times were
so what's amazing about our show is we
take everything good from the original
but we have those topical conversations
and we do evolve which i think makes for
a smarter
more enjoyable piece of television i
actually watched a few episodes i was
enormously impressed with dennis because
it's actually a very tricky job because
the the sweet spot on the show is this
gaggle of kids who are tight friends and
um
there is this referee walking around on
the field who
gets put into the dunk tank every now
and then it's sort of a tightrope act
and dennis was incredibly good at it do
you want to reach out to him to see like
well i can't there's there's spoilers
involved so i can't really
speak i always get in trouble okay i
know dear i can see that you there's
trouble in your eyes
i don't like it i'm just hoping over
here for a a principal titan and a
principal building
reunion of the sorts stay tuned okay
okay i like that tease i know it's
confirmed that we have lark voorhees
back for an episode
is there any chance that we would maybe
see dustin diamond
we definitely hear about screech like
where there's jokes about what he's
doing now and there's some easter eggs
about
uh about his life you know it was a hard
thing
this this season it's just 10 episodes
and in addition to
trying to find places to use the
original cast some felt more organic
because they're already parents of
um the students it's like you really
want to spend the majority of your time
with
these new characters as a fan of the
show sure i'd love to see screech and i
i would be open to it um if there was
another season
i'm one of a whole group of great
producers and
we're discussing but i just don't know
yet it depends on the story lines and
how they play out
and all of that but i i wish
dustin nothing but the best um i just
haven't seen him for
a lot of years but i do wish him the
best he was always kind to me
so there's a little invitation out there
that's waiting we'll see
i'm so excited i'm so excited
i absolutely screamed when i saw in the
trailer that you are gonna be revisiting
the iconic caffeine pill storyline
are those caffeine pills at first
they're so exciting and then
it gets even more exciting but after
that it gets so scary and in the end you
ruin your girl group shot at a recording
contract
what that is such an iconic moment in
pop culture history
how do you react when you see like memes
about it or or things just you know in
the lexicon
or people just coming up to me singing
i'm so excited
yes i'm so scared uh you know what
i love it i love that people embraced
that i mean we really
went for it i also have a good sense of
humor about myself
um but at the time you know mark paul
and i played it for real
we were using our guts you know in our
heart and we
trusted each other as actors we were
like best friends and so
in real life too so we really felt safe
enough to go there
because that episode really needed it i
think that's why we're so excited to
there we go then to bring it to you know
bring this show as a gift back to anyone
that grew up watching it so it's
nostalgic
but also to a new fresh audience because
the show is more progressive
um it obviously maintains so much of why
people loved it
so we didn't want to stray from that for
the og fans
one of the the most exciting parts of
this show at least for me as like a pop
culture super fan
were all the little easter eggs that you
sprinkled in and all the amazingly
topical
um celebrity references i got dj
khaled's baby to make you a playlist i
have a kardashian coming at lunch
rob shut up he's still in their family
can you walk me through a few that are
your favorite or that were
um i don't know the most fun to inject
into this series in terms of easter eggs
for the original show like
if that was one of the most fun things
about this like really
looking at spots where you could be like
oh
i bet we can get the exact guitar that
zach had when he was in zach attack or
we can put slater's wrestling singlet up
on his wall and it's always there
or the song that's playing at the max is
the song that zach put subliminal
messages in in the one episode
because franco worked on the original
show he would just be like oh i have a
i have a jacket from malibu wow god so
you sourced a lot of original props and
mementos some yes yeah there's a there's
a photo of kelly that's in
kelly and zach's bedroom yeah there were
a lot of times i was like
let me check my attic i might have that
you only know how bayside works for kids
like you
hot kids privileged kid privileged kids
i
really applaud the show because it has
absolutely prioritized
diversity and representation what does
it mean
to be on a show that is so inclusive it
means the world to me
simply because representation especially
for
young adults trying to find you know
where they fit in
it's so important like just to have
someone to look up to and say oh wow
this person looks like me
they did it um i can do it too but the
fact that
we have such a diverse cast that you
know when you tune in you kind of feel
included in
in this show and you feel represented
and especially for like latinas
you see daisy in a different light
versus
this drama cop series you know just the
girl from the bronx who probably got
knocked up and doesn't really have a
future
daisy is like no i have a future i have
a voice i'm gonna use it when i read the
character breakdown
with for daisy i relate it so much to
that
i feel like i always have to prove
myself because i'm latina and because i
have curves or
because i speak a certain way or because
i grew up a certain way
it meant everything to get to play this
role i mean it was such a cool
opportunity to get to portray a
character like this
that it wasn't all about her gender
identity i think that's what's so
important about representation now and
what we
look to for the work that we need to do
for representation in the future
getting to have these types of
characters but not making it all about
x all about race all about their gender
all about their sexual orientation
so getting to tell a genuine
well-written
storyline about a person who's a mean
girl
who's a fashionista who's a bad
belief but then also happens to be
transgender
is the coolest thing in the world i'm
gonna be honest ten episodes it's just
frankly not enough
what do you think about a season two
have you heard anything what do you
wanna see happen
it's a really bad thing in my business
i've become interested in this show
you know yeah i
can't quite remember a job that
i've been on in the last 10 20 years
where i'm
i would i would go to the set and watch
when i wasn't in the
scene which was very unusual for me um
and i'm interested in these kids i
really
am there's just so many stories to tell
about them 10 is not enough i agree
i i think we were ju we're just getting
started
it's about uh privileged kids who sort
of
need to meet kids who are different than
them and
um you know and how these new kids come
in sort of shape them and vice versa and
so
you know when you have a show that has
these two things in conflict it does
feel like you can
go on and on uh for for a bunch of
seasons
i had green light season two that's it
you asked me we are manifesting praying
that we can have a season two and
um you know speaking to what haskidi
said hopefully continuously
uplifting the communities that we're a
part of but we are in
in the dark we don't know anything for
sure but it'd be beautiful to know that
people enjoy the show and want to see
more so hopefully that is in the future
for us